what's up everybody it's Warren and we
have some awesome news today in the
world of Loki including an alternate
death scene that has recently been
revealed by Marvel and some casting news
about the series as well including
casting for a possible female Loki just
like from the comics and in this
alternate scene for Loki and Avengers
infinity war he may not have even died
when he gave the tesseract to Thanos so
we'll talk about what this means as well
and how this could affect the Loki
series so we're going to break that down
in this video quick reminder I'm still
doing my Xbox one and ps4 giveaway all
you have to do to enter is subscribe
with the notifications turned on like
the video and leave a comment down below
so recently some unused concept art has
come to light about Avengers infinity
war and as it turns out the way Loki
died in Avengers infinity war wasn't
necessarily always the way that they had
planned in an alternate version Loki
actually managed to get away from Thanos
and flee to his home world of Jotunheim
however that would have not stopped
Thanos from finding Loki in Avengers
infinity war as you can see here we have
concept art of Loki in Jotunheim and
Thanos is there as well he has come for
the tesseract now in this alternate
scene it would have went very
differently for starters it's only Loki
and Thanos in this scene Thanos doesn't
have his army
Loki doesn't have the other as guardians
it's just the two of them and it appears
as if they're both just talking now
remember Loki used to work for Thanos
Thanos is the one who gave Loki the
sceptre and gave him his army to attack
New York
Loki was supposed to give the sceptre
back and retrieve the tesseract for him
before and he failed and he lost both of
the Infinity stones so Fanus is probably
very upset with Loki but Loki doesn't
seem to really be putting up a fight
because Loki probably assumed that
eventually at some point in time he
would run into Thanos again Thanos is
the most powerful being in the universe
and Loki failed him so he probably
assumed that he'd see him eventually and
since it's one-on-one
there is no Hulk there is no Thor it
seems like Loki just gives him the
tesseract now based off of these photos
it does look like he has some sorrow but
Loki isn't really the one to just die an
infinity war he truly thought he could
defeat Thanos he truly thought the Hulk
could defeat him and then he thought he
could sneak up on him and stab him in
the neck but here it's just him there is
nobody else that he can rely on and
probably knows that he cannot defeat
Thanos so he gives him the tesseract
although he's not happy about it because
Trulli has turned to good if this scene
would have ended up in Avengers infinity
war not only would have infinity war
been different but the entire future of
the MC would have been different as well
remember what the writers and the
directors of infinity war and ingame
said fan OHS does not kill unless he has
to
he had the opportunity to kill many
Avengers and Avengers infinity war but
he never did because that's not what his
goal was his goal was to collect all of
the Infinity stones so there's a really
good chance that he could have left Loki
alive and simply left it to fate on
whether or not he would die when he
snapped his fingers and if that would
have happened the entirety of the MCU
would have shifted because Loki would
still then be alive unless he died in
the snap but that really wouldn't matter
either because then he would have been
brought back now it's very clear as to
why they didn't go this route especially
after Avengers end game came out the
2012 Loki escaped with the tesseract and
has now created an alternate timeline
one that is going to be explored during
the Loki series that has come in to
Disney Plus and if this scene would have
happened and Loki would have stayed
alive then the whole entire premise for
the Loki series would have been
completely different so although it
would have been really nice to see Loki
survive unfortunately that's not how it
went and speaking of the Loki series we
do have some very new and exciting news
about some new developments last Friday
it was revealed that actress Sophia
DiMartino was in talks to join the cast
of the Loki series on Disney Plus and
originally it was speculated that she
was going to be playing enchantress or
another Marvel Comics character from
Asgard but now it seems like the
character that she's in talked with
Marvel to play is a female version of
Loki this comes from deadline that says
one source close to the production hints
that DiMartino may in fact portray a
female incarnation of Loki and in effect
share the role with Hiddleston and if
you're wondering female loki is
definitely something that happens in the
comics and now it seems like fimo loki
is making her way into the Loki series
on Disney Plus and this is big news
because this will most likely tie into
Thor love and thunder where we're
already getting a female version of Thor
Jane Foster Thor
so when Thor love and thunder looks like
we could be having two different Thor's
and two different Loki's one being a
male and one being female if this is
truly the way that they're going what do
you think about this news let me know
down below in the comments and of course
don't forget
subscribe with the notifications turned
on and give the video a like so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 and if you'd like a
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet click
the link in the description down below
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof